So in the previous section,
we introduced character tables,
and we saw that we can think
about a multiple alignment
as a character table of its own, for
which each of the m columns of this
multiple alignment can be
viewed as a character.
Our goal is to use this multiple alignment
to reconstruct the most
likely ancestral sequences.
To do so, we're going to need
some way of determining how good
an assignment of ancestral
sequences is for a given tree.
For example, say that we're given
the following tree structure for
the four species that we've been
considering, and that we then assign
the following ancestral sequences
to internal nodes of the tree.
We're going to define the parsimony score,
then,
of this tree, as the sum of the Hamming
distances along each edge of the tree.
This tree has parsimony
score equal to eight.
And this discussion brings us to
the small parsimony problem, in which
we're given a rooted binary tree whose
leaves are labeled by strings of length m,
and our goal is to assign
ancestral sequences to this tree
in order to minimize the parsimony score.
Now, this seems like a difficult problem.
Is there going to be any
way of simplifying it?
If we treat the columns of the multiple
alignment that we're given as independent
of each other, then it means that
we'll be able to solve the small
parsimony problem on each column of
the multiple alignment separately.
In other words, we can work with one
symbol of each string at a time.
So we'll now design a dynamic programming
algorithm that will solve
the small parsimony problem, assuming
that each string is just a single symbol.
So first, define T_v as the subtree of
the given tree T whose root is node v.
Then define s_k(v) as
the minimum parsimony score
of the subtree T_v over all
possible labelings of T_v,
such that the node v is
labeled by symbol k.
Note that according to this definition,
the minimum parsimony score of
the entire tree T is equal to
the minimum value of s_k at the root,
taken over all symbols k.
The idea of our dynamic programming
algorithm, then, is going to start at
the leaves of the tree,
then compute the values s_k upward from
the leaves to the root, and then use this
fact to find the minimum parsimony score.
In order to implement this algorithm,
we're going to need a recurrence
relation for the score of a node v in
terms of its two children,
which I'll call its "son" and its "daughter".
So we can define sigma_i,j
to be 0 if the symbols i and
j are equal to each other.
And if i and
j are not equal to each other,
we define sigma_i,j to be equal to 1.
Because you're a dynamic
programming expert by now,
I'm going to leave proving this
recurrence relation to you.
So once you've demonstrated
this recurrence relation,
let's see how it works for an example.
So at each node v, an array is going to
hold the set of scores s_k(v) for
each possible symbol k.
Here we're going to be working with DNA, so
there will be four symbols k.
Because the leaves
are preassigned in our tree,
we're going to set their scores equal to
0 for the symbols of those leaves, and
infinity for all other symbols.
For example,
here the leaf is assigned C, so
we set the score of C equal to 0 and
the score of T equal to infinity.
Why would we do this? Well,
it prevents us from then going back and
changing the leaf node to t later.
It is something that we want to prevent, right?
So when we move up a level, we're going
to apply the recurrence relation.
In the left most node,
the two children are fixed as equal to C.
So the score of this node is
going to be 0 if we assign it a C,
since there will be no conflicts
between these two edges.
If we assign this node any other symbol,
then there will be two conflicts between
the edges, and its score is going to be 2.
One node over from this, we will obtain a
score of 1 if we assign this node an A or
a C, and a score of 2 otherwise
because we'll have two conflicts.
The remaining two nodes proceed similarly.
So, note that I'm using red to indicate
the minimum score at each step and
there may be a tie as we've
seen in two nodes here.
When we move up one
more level in the tree,
let's walk through the computation of,
say, the array of the left node.
The score of A corresponds to
the minimum parsimony score
over all possible
assignments to this subtree,
assuming that A is
assigned to that subtree.
In this case, the best that we can
do is not to take an A here, but
to take a C here, since the parsimony
score of that subtree will be equal to 0.
And then that will provide us with
a conflict of 1 on that edge.
In this case, we do want to take A because
the parsimony score of this subtree will
be 1, and then A will agree here.
In a sense, we're breaking the tie between
A and C if we assign that equal to A.
So we would have gotten a score
of 1 from this subtree, and
a score of 1 from this subtree,
so we assign A a score of 2.
C should be pretty straightforward because
C is a minimum at each of these two nodes.
So if we assign a C here and a C here,
we get parsimoniy scores of 0 and 1,
and we have no conflicts here.
So this is really what
the recurrence relation is saying.
So, two more examples.
For G, if we assume that we assign a G
there, then we don't want to assign
Gs here because that would give us
parsimony score of 4 here and 4 here,
and although we wouldn't have
any conflicts along these edges,
we would have a score of 4.
We can do better than that if we simply
assign Cs to both of these nodes,
in which case we get two conflicting
edges, so a contribution of 2,
but then a contribution of 0 and
1, which gives us 3.
The case of T follows analogously
because it's essentially the same as G.
So hopefully, you can see from that how
we can get the right node on this level,
as well as when we move to the root.
So when we move to the root,
the minimum parsimony score is going
to be corresponding to symbol C,
which means that we should assign C to
the root because we said that the minimum
parsimony score of the tree was
the minimum at the root over all symbols.
So, to reconstruct the other ancestral
states, you're going to need to flex your
dynamic programming muscles once again and
implement a backtracking approach
that goes from the root down to
the leaves and assign symbols.
I want you to note, when you do this, that
the red elements correspond to minima, but
they don't necessarily correspond to an
optimal assignment of ancestral symbols.
So, for example,
we're going to get into trouble
if we assign a T to this
right-most node in the tree.
So, I want you to make sure that your
backtracking approach is able to
reconstruct the tree shown on this slide
before you try to implement a solution for
the small parsimony problem.
Once you have done so,
you might find it interesting to
apply the SmallParsimony dynamic
programming algorithm to the tree we
previously constructed for coronaviruses.
What are the ancestral coronavirus
sequences that you obtain?
Also, it turns out that you can find the
most parsimonious labeling of the internal
nodes in an unrooted tree by placing
a root on an arbitrary edge,
solving the small parsimony problem for
the resulting rooted tree, and
then simply removing the root.